- 請問一下
我覺得我們這一季
它的那個水準的落差可能有點大
- 這一季啊
因為我們第一集講超級簡單的
講融資啦
今天聽說要講一個我覺得
比較難一點
我覺得有點難耶
這算是
所有理財裡面
這算是比較深奧的一點
對啊 那我們怎麼會這樣第一集超級淺白的
第二集就直接深入了
我們不是喜歡的有潛入深
久潛一深嗎
我們的前戲太短了
好 因為我們今天要聊的是一個特殊的商品
叫可轉債
可轉債其實應該叫可轉股
對 它是可轉股的債
所以簡直還是可轉債
因為講可轉股 怪怪的
因為畢竟它還是債
可是可轉股的債又太長
所以只要寫可轉債
太長也不好
要適中
對 沒錯
今天跟你聊完我才知道原來我的一個好同學
同班同學那麼厲害
厲害啊
他在家上過公司
你剛剛跟我講
我說哇塞這檔很厲害的
當財務長有一次課堂上跟我們分享
可轉債是個好東西
他們公司從來不缺錢
對 你們這他那家公司
我記得發到8了你知道嗎
發到8很強嗎
很強
可轉再可以發到8的其實也沒幾家
而且它不是什麼大公司喔
就是上櫃的一家
我覺得在上市櫃公司也算中小企業而已啦
對
那個發到8都發上癮了你知道嗎
發到8
所以這個同學對於操縱
對於觀察
股價很有心得喔
因為可轉這跟股價
當然
息息相關
球員跟裁判全部都他們的人
對啊 發的也是他們的
那利多什麼時候要公布也是他們的
好喔
所以他們可以盡情的來從可轉載裡面
獲得一些利益
不能只有他們玩
今天我們來教大家一起玩
一起玩 多批
多批 對
今天來講可轉載了
好 歡迎收看理財達人秀的
有仇必到第二季啦
好 我們在第二季的第一集
講的比較簡單喔
我們講的是融資喔
是給真的是比較新手小白喔
但是小哥這個人變化多端喔
今天第二集決定來一點深奧的喔
不曉得大家有沒有留意到
可轉債這個商品
大家想到可轉債是債嘛
債不是很無聊嗎
No 可轉債
其實它可以轉成股票的債券
所以它有兩種玩法
你可以玩可轉債本身
你也可以就可轉債
知道這檔股價什麼時候
要開始狂拉特拉
所以一種東西
兩種玩法
今天小哥要來好好地教大家了
這樣講得好像很超值
非常好
可轉債是個很好很好的商品
到底什麼是可轉債的
好複雜
可轉股票的債券
每次有人跟我講
小哥我做這個也賠錢
做那個也賠錢
那我到底要玩什麼比較好
我說你還買可轉債
對
我挑幾個98塊的給你買
再有什麼好玩的
98塊有保本100塊
真的嗎
保你賺
保你賺嗎
那萬一漲上去的話你賺更多
那萬一跌下去呢
你有還有100塊保本
保證賺
所以呢只要有這種人
我都推薦他來玩可轉債
好我們先來瞭解什麼是可轉債
但是這個保證賺
我們等一下也要修正一下
也是有小小時候會出問題
保證賺的
我們說有擔保保證賺
好
無擔保就不一定
到底什麼可轉債
到底何謂可轉債
那可轉債它的名字比較拉長一點
它叫可轉換公司債
還是聽不懂
簡稱可轉債又叫CB
這個我們慢慢解釋
那第一個呢 它是發行公司擔保
要有擔保喔
各位你記得是發行公司喔
對
所以假如這家公司爛的話
它那種擔保可能沒有用喔
所以台積電發
嗯
一定的
台積電絕對沒問題
那什麼電發不行
紅海也沒問題
紅插電呢
最近有一 紅插電應該也沒問題啦
看它最近噴成這樣
那最近有一檔股票看起來有問題
那你就要小心一點
所以呢
所以你沒有講名字啊
三個字 都英文的
都英文的
我們待會會講到這檔
那很容易猜
最近都一直在跌停
那這個看起來就有點問題
好的
那發行公司擔保
可以轉換成股票的債券
那通常發行公司擔保
他這個各位可能覺得緊張
發行公司萬一這個倒怎麼辦
所以可轉債他又有分兩個
一個是有擔保
一個是無擔保
都已经怕他倒了 我还无单啊
对啊 所以你假如真的怕他倒
你去买有单的
有单的 那这个他的发行文件上面都有写
你就挑有单的买
你就不用怕他倒了
好 不是 那无单的有什么好处
无单的
都无单了 我还买它
无单的比较便宜啊
原来是价差大是不是
对对对 无单的
这个有单的可能110几块
无单的可能就剩100几块
好 无单的会比较便宜
比较便宜
好那第二個呢
公司缺資金的時候
他可以用較低利息
或者是不用還錢的籌資工具
不用還錢
我知道了
可以轉換成股票
用股票跟你換回來就好了
那股票要應多少就應多少
我們買可轉債
我問一下趙華你猜
你猜我買可轉債
我希望他還錢
還是希望他不要還錢
不是 你欠債還錢天經地義嘛
欠債不還錢 你是在布施做功德嗎
沒有 我們特別喜歡他不還錢
他不還錢要還什麼 身體嗎
他不還錢 他就必須要怎麼樣
可以轉換成股票嘛
嚇死我了
所以不還錢 你把股價拉起來就不用還了
好 我就願意換成股票
不跟你拿現金了
對 我願意換成股票
因為股票你拉起來
我股票在市場上賣多漂亮啊
像最近的長榮 長榮行
多個行字 不是長榮
長榮行 華航
哇 最近的股價噴翻了
我願意換股票
我願意
這個換成 最近的華航
哇塞 那個可轉債
這個成交大幅上升
就是一堆已經把可轉債換成股票了
小哥可能還願意換空姐
好
可以換的話當然可以
那第三个呢对投资人来说
你就可以在约定时间内
假如股价高于转换价
对
转换价很重要
高于转换价的话
我就愿意
把债券
这个用约定价格换成股票
假设转换价50
可是股价55
那我当然换股票
当然换啊
我换成股票
因为我可以换到50块的股票啊
那你这样子的话呢
你可以在市场上的卖比较多钱
好
那第二个呢
當股價低於轉換價的時候
那到期若公司沒倒的話
保本至少還錢
至少還錢 還你100
可轉帳最少還100
那有擔保的沒問題一定有100
那沒擔保的就不一定
像之前的復興航空公司
他在倒之前他的可轉帳剩下40 50塊
你不是說要還我100嗎
就人家倒了
所以4050塊這個就看你要不要
好 那可轉債呢
他就從此享有股權
債權的投資工具
你可以當作他是債權
當股價一直跌 沒關係你有債
當股價一直噴 沒關係你有股
股價一直跌我就當債主
股價一直漲我就當股東
對 沒錯
一種產品兩種用途
兩種選擇嘛
所以呢這個很多人說
健達出其彈對啊沒有置入健達有沒有可轉載好像沒有那有人講我買股票會賠你買可轉債啊
100塊保底嘛
對不對 你去買9899塊的
就至少有100塊的保證
如果是正派經營的公司
對 買有擔保的
好 我怎麼知道誰有發可轉債
那怎麼知道呢
這個我們的貴買中心的網頁
债券市場資訊就有拉
那可轉載的資訊在這邊通通都有
可轉載要看貴買中心喔
不是證交所
是貴買中心喔
他管的喔
對 貴買中心管的
那這邊呢 我們來看一下
這邊就有債券代號像這個
左登2
那這可轉載的數字都是五個字喔
左登2KY
那發行人這邊就寫了
發行日期 到期日期 年限
可轉帳通常都是3到5年
是 那發了多少錢呢
這邊也會寫出來
那重點是後面的發行資料
你就可以點進去看
好 所以這邊有
因為D加還真不熟
後面有什麼化汗啦
對 後面有幾個熟的 比較熟一點
後面我們就來講化汗
那首先呢
我們現在講這可轉帳優缺點
到底優缺點是什麼
優點第一個保本風險D
剛剛講保100保底
有擔保的一定是保本
第二個交易成本低
很低嗎
可轉債你現在買賣
不用交易稅
真假
真的
所以你喜歡當沖的
可轉債是不能當沖
但是你有庫存的話
像有時候我有庫存
我來幫忙造勢
就是賣盤我掛一點
買盤我也掛一點
那有时候两边成交
好像我在当冲一样
是
那这个呢
还不用交易税
不用交易税
先记起来
交易成本还蛮低的
好
那股票上涨的时候呢
可转债享有跟股票同样的好处
也会涨
我们今天会讲几个上涨的案例给你看
好
那缺点呢
第一个
有被公司方提前赎回的风险
有听过
我现在不想发债了
我要把它钱赎回来
我可以決定這樣做
那這種缺點
其實這種缺點都是怎麼樣
你會發現你好像賺的比較少
因為通常提前輸位的都是這樣子
第一 漲太多
可轉太
對 漲太多
因為提前輸位至少漲到130塊以上
漲太多的他會提前輸位
那像去年有個
今年有個很誇張案例叫做陽明
哇 陽明真的噴翻了
陽明噴翻了
但是你知道嗎
陽明可轉債
假如沒有提前輸回的話
它可轉債最高價可以到多少錢
你知道嗎
多少錢
你說本來100塊的東西變2200
變2200
不就跟股票一樣
它漲了二幾倍啊
對啊 因為股價噴翻了
那它在200多塊被輸回了
所以公司可以決定在某個價格把它輸回
對 公司就會通知你
陽明趕快來輸回
那這樣就代表股價後面會噴啊
有可能
因為它跟隨著航運類股的航行起來
公司發現不對勁了
一種被軋空的感覺
不過那時候你假如把核轉載都換成股票
抱它一段
很棒
那也是有2200的意義
所以如果公司要提前輸輝
我也可以說我要現在換成股票
通常公司提前輸輝的時候
就叫你換成股票
就是叫我換成股票
你也可以在市場上賣
可是在市場上賣的價格通常比較爛一點
你就可以直接把它換成股票
在市場上賣
好 那第二個缺點呢
公司倒閉的風險
這個公司倒閉呢
這個最近有幾家啦
不過我跟你講
可轉在這個不倒則已啊
一倒就要坐牢了
所以公司不大敢讓他倒
因為他這是欠債的 跳票了嘛
對 這個上次最明顯的案例
就是很多人受傷的案例叫做熱身
熱身案
勒森你看許金龍現在還在監牢裡面
還在關
所以這個通常有人問說
小哥我買這顆轉債會不會有點危險
我說大部分
你只要不要去買那個6-70塊的殼轉債
因為6-70塊你看離100塊那麼遠
大部分你買98塊99塊的
通常都沒有問題
因為只要公司一倒
那負責人要坐牢的
所以通常公司不會讓他倒
好 想盡辦法還錢 幫他坐牢囉
好 那這個可能還有一個缺點
流動性風險
對耶 交易量有的很少
對 你知道為什麼那麼少嗎
因為我們理財達恩秀到現在才在講啊
很多人不曉得有可轉在這種東西呢
不要這樣 我們之前有個算力教官
偶爾會講講
會講
大概很久了 很久了 對
好
所以他的交易量比較少
會不會有進出上面價差的問題
或是我賣不掉呢
常常會這樣
好 注意囉
好 這個通常也不會說你賣不掉
你賣便宜一點
那個城市交易都要來吃
是
因為你賣便宜一點
這個他發現有套利的機會
那就把你吃掉
好 那公司發債最終的目的
是
第一個還錢
誒 借錢還錢
天經地義
我們最討厭
最討厭你還錢
為什麼
因為我最喜歡二
第二個拉抬股價
上到點
上到點好不好
讓可轉債換成股票
是
你知道我有一次買了潤泰權的可轉債
然後呢
我到現在還在恨那個
那個
那個頭髮比較
尹先生嗎
頭髮比較少的那個人
為什麼要恨他你知道嗎
我買了一堆
對
我就認為說
那時候轉換價我記得69塊
才69塊
你的股價69塊
轉換價69 股價68
差一塊啊
臨門一腳 那時候還有一個月
我買了一團國 它的可轉載買100.5的
你知道嗎
我想說它只要拉一根的話
我這100.5就賺翻了
我頂多賠100塊保本嘛
我頂多賠0.5 幹嘛不怕
結果到後來它真的沒了
我就買了一堆啊 奇怪怎麼買了一堆
算一算 我在市場上買了
這個也好幾百張了
那我不是直接買可轉載
我是買可轉載的選擇權
比較便宜 以後來教大家
那個太進階了
那買了一堆 結果後來真的沒了
好 所以還是有賠錢
對啊 因為從100.5變成100塊
他是真的還錢
很 幹嘛還錢給我
好 拉起來多好
拉起來你開心我開心
好 那第三個呢
信用差的公司
對 你要怎麼界定信用差呢
信用差呢
我們有個東西叫信頻
信頻呢
它是個付費資料
你要知道自家公司的信頻
信頻數字有1到9
1到9 1到3是好公司
像台積電那肯定都在1到3裡面的
對1到1
台積電的腳來跟銀行借錢
你猜銀行會怎麼樣
哎呀拜託利率月低
花銀啊 就借你啦
都借你 台積電護國神山
對不對 1% 0.9%
都借給你 幾乎要送你 但是不行
對 越低利也沒問題
信用好的公司
他缺錢直接去銀行借
都借得到
那信用差呢 信頻7到9
他跟銀行借錢 不好意思 可不可以跟你借點錢
銀行就說隔壁有當鋪
那個公司有什麼可以拿去點檔的
可以去那邊借
所以信頻差的公司呢
他發可轉債
發可轉債也是要錢的喔
你發行中間你還要付一些費用
發可轉債大部分是為了不還錢
所以如果他現金不夠多的公司發可轉債
你就可以期待他將來要還你股票
有機會拉一波啊
那這種拉了一波之後
特定人賺到錢
誰是特定人呢
就是持有可轉債的人
好 那公司呢 籌到錢
也籌到錢 雙贏耶
對啊
那各位你想想看我們有一句話叫能量守恆定律怎麼可能大家都賺錢沒有人賠錢呢那誰賠錢呢
其實呢最後吃虧的就小股東
你說抱著股票的小股東嗎
我抱著你這張股票
原本股本是5億的
怎麼發了可轉戰之後股本變10億
因為都換成股票啦 股本膨脹啦
股本膨脹了嘛
那我的EPS就縮水了
所以沒有玩到這小股東
發現股價怎麼上去
又下來
回到原點
他假如沒有學過可轉債
他就不曉得有中間這一端
所以發可轉債多的公司要留意了
小股東
好
那公司呢
我們假如知道
他這個
發債的炒作
流程的話
那我們就可以跟著他
大家一起玩
對 報上又報下
上面多單先賺一波
下面榮券再賺一波
所以公司發債是有SOP的
好的
首先第一個 低檔發可轉債
所以通常是低檔嗎
不一定
沒有喔
你只好看到股價高檔發可轉債
那代表這家公司
它的財務人員不及格
就沒有你那個同學那麼厲害
你拿個同學嘛
我觀察很久都是低檔發債的
而且發到8次
百發百中
哎呀 這同學就厲害了
第二個呢
發完債之後
三個月內是不能換的
不過這三個月內有時候股票就拉了
股票就拉了
為什麼呢
因為我們就發現
哎呦 營收突然增加了
對
灌營收
不一定用灌的啦
好消息刚好来了吗
刚好来了
第二个找新的题材
还有最近可多了
最近很多
最近我们看到很多营建股
都是E3开头的
E3不是化工股吗
化工人家转营建嘛
借壳嘛
那这种就新的题材
这个盖房子
像以前做胶带的也来盖房子
做化工的也来盖房子
做纺织的也来盖房子
对 这种我们就喜欢
这种就是摆明要吵的嘛
第三个呢 找人配合拉抬股价
我怎么知道他找了谁
找了谁
反正你假如在电视上看到
怎么有个老师一直在喊这档股票
那他就是他们找的人
就找人配合
如果他有發可轉載
然後有人不停的喊這檔有發可轉載的股票
就合理小小懷疑他這樣
然後你打開手機本來要下單的時候
這檔股票有異常節目推薦
你這樣會講到我的理財達人秀
好像偶爾也會有這個問題
不能這麼說
有的話
有時候我們是剛好講到
那假如是真的有人蓄意找人配合講股票的話
股票的話
我相信理財都不會有這種情形
我們都叫人家不要追啊 被罵
對 每次叫人家不要追
好 那第四個呢
股票高檔的時候
那可轉代的市值呢
市值就會大於120
市值大於120
市值待會教你算
那高檔你發現融券大增
那這120都算是低標
比較厲害的都炒到150 200
是 比較厲害的
那第五個呢 可轉債你會發現成交量大增了
你發現成交量大增
代表可轉債是有人在換手
那第六個呢 過幾天後發現現卷償還
這好難喔 現卷償還是這樣
我們大概講一下
因為呢 可轉債呢 在往上漲的過程中
那你可转账要卖
可能也卖不到好的价钱
那有的人呢
他就先去农券放空
我先农券空
然后再来卖这个账
农券空了之后呢
我再把可转账换成股票
那我手上有农券
有股票
我就可以做一个动作
叫现券偿还
就是把我的股票跟农券
两个合并
合并叫现券偿还
所以通常高檔你看到限卷偿款
那行情可能是先告一个段落
告一个段落
等于他已经套现回来了嘛
对 没错
好 用这样的想法
但是它比较难
我们以后进阶班
我们以后呢
可能是来教我们现在讲前面
因为前面光是要算它的转换价什么
我就还不会嘛
我先教你坐多的
好
我先教你北上列车
北上列车坐多
之后有空再教你南下列车
好 做工
好 那这个交之前呢
我们要讲一个最最基本的
叫转换成股票的计算方法
这么算
第一个呢
你要知道这档股票的可转债的转换价
好
那转换价呢
它就是转换张数呢
会等于100除以转换价
原来是这样子
对 因为可转债呢
发行的面额呢
都是100块
一张都是10万
是
所以用這個來算的就公道
公道好
那第二個假設你發行的時候
通常是發行前兩個禮拜
他去看那兩個禮拜股價大約是多少
那發行的時候
股價假如是在20塊附近的話
那你想想看啊
20塊附近你有10萬塊的錢啊
你有10萬塊
你要買股票你可以買幾張
買5張嘛
所以你假如去買可轉
可转在理论上哇那你可以换5张嘛
对 公道
公道
好那假设发行的时候
前两个礼拜
平均的价格呢是50块
50块
那你假如是有10万块的人
你就可以买两张
那你假如去买可转在
理论上你也要可以换两张啊
对
所以呢转换价呢就这么算的
哦
转换价呢
这个转换张数就等于100
除以转换张数
好
100除以轉換價
那你換成股票之後
我們就可以來算一個轉換後的市值
對 剛剛講市值不是很懂
不是很懂
因為我們一般市值是股本乘以它股價除以10
但這個不是吧
這個不是
這市值我教你怎麼算
叫做市場的價值
對 市場的價值
假設轉換價是20
那轉換張數就是5
你可以換5張
那現在股價到30了
股價到30
你原本20塊買5張的
原本20塊買5張你有10萬
現在到30塊你就變15萬了
直接乘就對了
所以可轉代的市值就等於30乘以5
就等於150
現在問題這是市值
市值不一定等於市價
它應該有這個價值
還有這個價值
但是不見得能呈現在它的價格上
對 有時候你150
我不是值150嗎
你150你掛著賣賣不掉
賣不掉
你賣148他就可以賣掉
就掛低點賣就可以了
那股價等於40的話
CP的市值就等於40乘以5
等於200
你看轉換價漲一倍
其實CP相對也是漲一倍
對 轉價固定
應該說股價漲一倍
股價啦股價
股價漲一倍
CP的市值也會漲一倍
也有找一遍
那这个比较特别的是怎么样
是股价假如等于10
对
股价等于10
那CP的市值不就等于50吗
对啊 因为股价都对折了
对 好那CP市值等于50
那问你 那你要换吗
股票吗
你要从债权人变成股东吗
不要 你刚刚有教我
有担保的他还我100
对 我就咬紧你
对 所以可转贷有这好处就是
这个只要股价跌我就不换
不換
說不換就不換
股價漲我才換
對 我們最希望股價漲
好 那我們來舉個案例
好 來 這個案例是64143化汗3他也發到第三批了就對了那為什麼舉這案例呢因為他曾經有漲停過通常這個可轉債
他要拉之前
他會先漲停一下
讓各家來看
我有曾經漲停過哦
鼓勵展示就對了
對 曾經漲停過
好 那這場化汗3
他轉換價是223.2
對
那轉換張數就等於100除以223.2
就等於0.45張
所以還有那種不到一張的
0.45張而已
換成股價不到一張
那現在我們算他的市值
現在大概是95塊附近
才95塊
我們把這個0.45去乘以股價
約莫在95塊附近
所以這種我們就可以期待他
有機會拉超過轉換價
從95拉到223.5嗎
不是 標的成交價目前是213.5
那轉換價223
只要拉過223
那麼這個市值就會突破100了
是
就這樣看
所以我們就期待他
有機會拉過轉換價
我發現這中間有一個小小的問題是
他現在算起來
以他的股價算回來對不對
他的市值只有95
可是市場上已經賣到111
對
這不就代表大家買這個可轉債人認為
後面會拉股價嗎
沒錯
所以我們每次去判斷這檔可轉債
有沒有機會拉的時候
對
我們會特別看可轉債的價格
他這樣溢價
對 溢價越多的話
對
你想想看溢價越多
因為可轉債通常拿的人
通常你要想一下可轉債是誰拿到的
對啊 特定人
特定人拿到
那特定人為什麼
到了120 130還不賣呢
對呀
市值不是才90幾年
為什麼120不賣呢
對
那特定人想說
他會拉到120以上嘛
對不對
所以我們就可以從可轉債的價格
對
去猜測公司的企圖
而且股價上
如果我今天沒可轉債
我好歹可以做股價
對
所以可轉債這邊呢
你學會看之後
對你看股票會很有幫助
好
那接下來我問一下趙華
這個明年呢
二月多啊
二月底
這個華安山呢
他可以用101.51
賣回給公司啊
對
我問你啊
你想賣回嗎
這是華安山目前的無檔狀況
對
你會想用101.51賣回嗎
怎麼可能
怎麼可能嘛
市場上賣就好了嘛
對啊
市場上現在110塊可以賣嘛
所以通常這個賣回權
通常是給
比较不好公司的卖回的
不好公司
像之前的复兴航空公司
摔了两架飞机嘛
就一堆拿复兴航空公司可转载
他要求说你帮我卖回
帮我这个这个做回去
所以卖回全这样看的
那最近呢有一家公司
最近也有点风险了
这家公司是这个48032的
VHQ KY
那為什麼他說他有點危險呢
因為他最近的可轉債
只剩下52塊
腰斬耶 剩52塊
發行的時候是100塊
現在剩52塊
賣回價103塊
沒關係我撐一下
我到期我賣回
那你要撐到什麼時候
我還可以100塊賣回
撐到2022年10月14號
快到了快到了
還有
現在快跨年了
還有快一年了
你買這檔52塊的
你記得每天在你家燒香拜拜的時候
順便提一下48032
拜託PHQ這家公司
塵埋不堂得
千萬不要倒
你用台語講英文可能聲明不見得理解
對
還有講英文跟這台語
好 那這個看起來就有點危險了
那即便它的賣回價是103
我們也建議你不要去買這家公司的客傳債
有可能還不出來是不是 有可能還不出來
通常是有可能還不出來才會出現這種價格
因為你想想看
你現在買到明年它還得出來
那是翻倍
不過歷史上有沒有這種後面又還出來的股票呢
好像有 還是有
所以我沒有說他一定還不出來
只是我不會想去買
可能他就是一個賭賭看的概念
但是他有可能還得出來
那通常這種還不出來的
會坐牢的
像這個樂森的許金龍就這樣子
好的
所以我們就靜待明年10月
看是還錢還是坐牢嗎對不對
對 好
那接下來我們講這個
簡單的可轉代操作法
第一個只要市值超過100
走勢會跟個股連動
就很健康的感覺
很健康
那第二個短線主力買超
市值角低於120的話
它有可能會拉抬
可是主力買超是買個股還是買客轉債
個股
因為客轉債我們沒有在看主力的
都看個股
我們舉例來看
最近噴出的案例
當然有4點
當然有2點是比較空單的
就勸幫的
那個我們下次再交
我們2點 對
後面才講
因為時間的關係
那我們這個來看一下
這最近噴出的長榮行
這個又是符合
知道我還記得我們之前講的嗎
主力買尚魁翹
誰開心
這個老婆開心
老公也開心
股民也開心
那各位你看一下
翹的不是股票
不只股票
連可轉債也翹起來
下面是可轉債的價格
可轉債從110幾也噴到快160
所以可轉債一拉也是快五成
一拉也是快五成
所以可轉債只要過了轉換價
我們看轉換價多少
轉換價是19.2
股價過了轉換價之後
可轉債就跟著噴
這邊更正一下
那邊是一個成交量
其實成交量是在網上移一點點
這一條線是可轉債的價格
對 大家要留意囉
對
好
那接下來我們來看這個
26107的華昂七
它的轉換價
轉換價各位看一下
轉換價是19塊
對
19塊
華昂過了19塊之後
對
可轉載的價格也跟著噴
是
從110也噴到了160
那這個也是主力大買的股票
所以短線主力買超
假如市值
市值低於120的話
市值我們是指這個轉換後的市值
他就有可能會拉抬了
那我要買殼轉債還是買個股呢
買殼轉債有保底的優惠
買個股就比較刺激
所以就是任均選擇
當你部位很大很大的時候
你買殼轉債沒有那個為那量
你就買股票就好了
原來是這樣
當你還想保底的時候
你就買殼轉債
是這樣子的
但是有提到
因為一般人會有債券的部位比較大
不是
可轉債它的交易規模
應該會比它的現股還要小對不對
小很多
所以如果是大量之間的
反而不能買可轉債
就去做現股吧
對不對
做現股可以
好
所以大家聽完一定會很好奇
假設我真的不太熟可轉債
我到底能不能
我就不做可轉債
但是我從觀察它去做個股呢
好
這個在進階的榮耀班
會來教大家
我看著可轉債
我來做獻股的秘訣喔
好 今天非常謝謝小哥喔
這可轉債可能一集講不完
今天先講一個入門的喔
讓你了解公司發可轉債
其實是很聰明的行為喔
尤其是大部分的公司
他是不想還錢給你的喔
他是希望還股票
那太棒了
因為大部分買可轉債的人
也希望你不要還錢給我喔
你是還股票給我喔
好 所以一種商品
你可以做債
你也可以做股
是一個非常棒的選擇
值得你來練習來認識囉
那今天的歌有求必報就到這邊囉
我們下次再見 掰掰
掰掰